oh
oh if you're being super nice to a girl
that she'll be receptive and like you
and
oh yeah don't be yourself especially if
yourself it is
not charismatic or charming but but
there is there is a double-edged sword
don't try to be something you're
not at the same time like let no no no
no okay okay okay hear me out hear me
out
like if you're if you're a quiet guy
don't try to be the center of attention
like it's just gonna be awkward
you know what i mean like
like try to make yourself better
but like don't you can't change your
whole personality you know
what do you want me to talk
about i don't know because there's like
be yourself all right
and you have to figure out what parts of
you are annoying
because there's some of it
yeah what what parts of you do girls not
particularly like
maybe tone those down but then figure
out what parts of yourself do girls
actually like
okay like i'll give you an example for
me i'm very self-aware right
i'm very likable people when they meet
me tend to like me however they think
they think i'm stupid
no i know no no not because you've heard
me talk but like when i i've
again self-aware i've done like things
where people can like
i've gotten data on this
actually
um because of the way i talk i come off
like kind of dumb
right like yeah
because you found me on a long-form
platform but like if i'm like day-to-day
just like talking to somebody and we
don't talk about like these ideas like
i'm very bubbly so i come off like kind
of ditzy i've gotten that a lot i
probably am a little bit you know like
it's somewhere but like so an example
no
no it's
no i've i've gotten this a lot from
employers actually where at first
they'll think i'm kind of ditzy and
they're like what what higher is this
yeah but
but the problem is then um
but then i'm like a hard worker so my
boss is always like me but what i'm
saying is like the guy equivalent of
that is like so what i do is i come off
a little bit dumb before debates so i
catch people off guard i did this
unfresh and fit
because i debated them very well the
first time i went on
and um like if you watch the full video
but
yeah fresh and fit when i went on
but
does that make sense
yeah
yeah
but that's what i'm saying like like you
can and you know maybe the ditzy thing
is attractive to men so turn that up
turn it down but like you gotta figure
out what parts of yourself are likable
to women and what parts of yourself
aren't and maybe show them the parts
that are not likable to women later
rather than sooner but you have to like
get
yeah
but you have to get like someone that's
going to be honest with you and give you
that feedback
and that's hard to find so good luck
oh god
oh no
um
i don't know my the things that creep me
out is guys that are too pushy with sex
that creeps me out
earlier
um
ah
i think if a guy
like
this is what i noticed with a lot of the
pickup guys
they stay
like like the
no no no no like it was good
because
like as a girl you're kind of going like
hot and cold hot and cold like some
things are gonna be hot some things are
gonna be cold you're like kind of trying
to decide
and so
uh
and so
then the the beta the beta guys will
sense like the cold parts and just like
cower away and not talk to her and get
like scared or whatever but the guys
that like
seem to have more success just like kept
talking to the girls not not crazy long
like you don't follow her around all
night but like they kept talking to her
until like they sort of had like a
common interest
yeah and then left
does that make sense
like they had the confidence to like
even if things were a little awkward or
off they just kept going sorry go ahead
oh god
i don't think i'm going to be very good
but
okay
okay
mm-hmm
okay
i would
you're sitting i would say
hi my name is pearl what's your name
okay paul
oh my gosh okay i would say hi my name
is paul
um
okay
oh my god that's how you talk to people
what the [ __ ]
oh
okay
oh god i would not know what to do with
that
um okay vodka soda
maybe a little less attitude next time
huh
you know that's bad
i kind of like it when guys like
like give me banter to be honest
no
yeah
oh my god i don't think i can
um
i'll get a ginger ale
no
just the one
ah target i can't
i
i'm not used to like most people are
nice like that i talked to
um do you have friends where are they at
[Music]
okay
um
i'll be like i have i have zero friends
none
no friends i came here by myself
yeah
do you want to play hangman
i'm not i'm not oh my god i'm not i told
you i don't want to do this
no i'm like i don't know how to talk to
girls
you know
what
i know i don't know
let's switch okay
no pun
okay um
all right i'm shimmying
i'm with my cat friend gabby
what no she's fine we're just [ __ ]
[Music]
oh wait that you're talking to god
oh
i don't drink
oh you're talking to gabby okay
um
what you guys doing
oh i'm pearl
um no but i'll take a ginger ale
okay wait wait wait
i'm high on life man
although that's what stoners say so
maybe that's not a good move
am i
no
no i'm shimmying
no i'm shimmy and you want to shimmy
with me
[Music]
sorry i'm not interested
okay
okay
i'm jealous
okay
oh no
i missed the love of my life
oh my god well that would have changed
everything
i thought you were 5-1
because that car wouldn't change
anything if you were 5-1
i'm not i don't drink but
but
i do get pretty hyper sometimes and i'm
getting in my hyper mood so i think the
shimmy brought it out of it
okay so i'm jealous now i'm jealous now
oh no he's eight feet tall
i missed it
oh okay
oc walked away
hey
uh
okay i'll try
okay i'll try again i'm gonna be the guy
this time i'm ready i got nervous
what no
i kind of am a little perched
[Applause]
okay wait
hold on
wait
so
so
uh
okay
hello ma'am
hello ma'am
i did
um
first of all the name is jayrid
second of all
i'll take a ginger ale
yeah and i hand you my private banking
card
no i i handed it
i handed it to you
i like sound effects okay
i'm good baby how are you
okay what's your name
a for real damn
did
alexa
[Laughter]
alexa alexa where are you from
i'm killing it
no i know actually i know that i just
thought it would be funny
i hate it when guys call me
i just thought it'd be funny
okay okay
okay
okay i forgot where i was okay where are
you from tory
yeah do you live around here
oh wow
[Music]
um
they they lied on the at the dmv i'm 5 8
okay
it's not
okay let's let me let me just let me
just let me just take the id back
is it fake
wait
i was going to but for you i was going
to but for you i'll stay a little longer
um how about dinner instead
[Laughter]
tomorrow at 7
you don't
kayaking
okay
tomorrow
at three
okay
4 30.
[Laughter]
does it
then you ghost her right back [ __ ]
block the number
okay
no i can't do tuesday
but i can do
monday
um
i don't know i think i think i i think i
think once isn't that big of a deal but
like if she does it more than once
yeah
[Music]
okay
okay
i don't know because
let me think
oh that would have been a good one i
didn't think about that yeah i'll pick
you up
wow
role play yeah
pearl as a man gets cussed out and
slapped in 12 seconds offensive
offensive
which one
oh okay okay
i thought you were saying i thought you
were going somewhere else with that i
was like for what
um
what a girl
jennifer is a female
like
[Music]
you'll find out
nothing they say before the breakup
matters once they decide to leave you
um
so
so
um
afraid of being alone
yeah i think men are able to be alone
better than women
because women um tend to value
relationships men value things or ten
like
women tend to like go into fields that
are more relationship driven indicating
that they value relationships more than
men
or men
trauma
huh
how did you oh you were bartending
before that's how you met people
i know i am looking for a co-host right
now it's like i wish it was you actually
i wish you were here because i know
you'd actually like know stuff and do
things
[Laughter]
show up
but but but all of our shows would be
late
[Laughter]
what are you
um
online dating
i like hit
i like hinge
yeah i like hinge well
yeah sort of it's okay that's my
favorite one
i'm supposed to go for a fuckboy
okay
but you could also not if you don't want
to
oh you should go to like high-end
restaurants like with the bar like by
the downtown chicago maybe
i feel like that'd be better than like a
bar
like a restaurant you know
oh
but then and then die alone
or bring people to you that's what i do
i do
the podcast in my apartment
hmm
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
well where do you where did you date him
before or something or you just knew him
okay
why didn't it work out to beta
oh
also meet up with him you might as well
go see
what's a date
oh
okay then maybe maybe not
to
to hook up
okay but we why'd you respond though if
you're not interested at all you seem a
little interested
um
hmm
what oh that's weird
[Applause]
okay
mhm
this guy sounds weird
oh my god can i read you okay
[Applause]
so
probably
wait can i can i can i read one
this is funny
okay i'm